as the official Hogwarts Legacy account
continues to trickle out small bits of
information about the game we're also
seeing a continued increase in smaller
little potential leaks I guess you could
call it and they are all centered around
one thing and that is the release date
for Hogwarts Legacy so I want to start
with the most recent bit of news first
and then we're kind of going to work our
way backwards from there I gotta give a
shout out to Luke 73 TNT on Twitter who
screenshotted this and sent it over to
me this was also posted on the Harry
Potter game subreddit but if you're
wondering what exactly this is if you
pull up the email on your phone you're
usually going to see who it's from at
the top and then you're going to have
the subject line and then very often
there will be a brief preview of what's
going to be in the email so here you can
see this one right here Xbox news at
GameStop and then score on Xbox series X
with Xbox all access and then in the
little preview text it says pre-order
Hogwarts Legacy collector's edition now
it was just a few short weeks ago that
some folks found hidden within the code
on the actual Hogwarts Legacy website
there there was some information hinting
around at a collector's edition also a
digital deluxe edition and as I have
cautioned folks from the beginning on
that even though it was found on the
website that was not public information
which means it's not confirmed it may
have been put there who knows when by
Avalanche and plans could have certainly
changed since it was put there could
have just been put there as a test for
when they do have something official to
announce they would just want to get it
ready who knows so while we can
certainly use it to speculate and hope
that some of those things are going to
be in the ultimate collection Edition
that we see we can't take it to the bank
as 100 confirmed just yet I do think
there's going to be a collector's
edition I think it would be a huge
mistake and would leave a lot of money
on the table if they don't do one so I
think it's gonna happen but it hasn't
been announced officially yet and we
still don't have a release date for the
game I could absolutely see them
announcing the collector's edition and
the release date for the game at the
same time which is exactly what we saw
just happened with God of War Ragnarok
so whenever we do get that release date
announcement I think that is the point
that we'll also get a collector's
edition announcement as well if they're
going to do one which again fingers
crossed they are so now you might be
asking well what exactly exactly is in
this email right well here's where it
gets pretty odd because in the body of
the email itself there is no mention of
Hogwarts Legacy at all so it seems like
this was actually a mistake the op over
on Reddit actually searched their email
in the plain text so essentially they
took it down to the code searched
everything and again Hogwarts Legacy
doesn't show up at all so I think some
of us were hoping that maybe they leaked
a little bit more in that plain text
email that we'd be able to find out but
there is nothing at all unless you look
at the exact HTML which shows that
preview text about pre-ordering the
Hogwarts Legacy collector's edition now
I was on vacation so I didn't get to
make a dedicated video on this but just
a few days ago we also had a situation
with the official Harry Potter art book
and it seems like the official title for
that is the art and making of Hogwarts
Legacy exploring the unwritten Wizarding
World now if you live in the US and you
go and search this on Amazon I'll put a
link in the description below it
currently has a December 31st release
date and that is what it has had for a
while on a number of different websites
however the thing that changed recently
is in the UK Japan Portugal and Italy
all of those Amazon websites have
updated this date to now say December
6th which is a date that has long been
speculated by Hogwarts Legacy fans as a
potential release date for Hogwarts
Legacy now after seeing that I did some
double checking on my own Walmart Google
Books Barnes Noble and Amazon us all
still have the late December 31st which
again is just a placeholder date they
all still have that they do not show
December 6th but again clearly this was
something that was manually triggered
someone at Amazon in those various
countries had to go in and say okay we
need to flip the switch on this the
question is why did they get some sort
of reliable information on when the art
book is releasing and even if that part
is confirmed this is what everybody has
to make sure they remember even if that
part is confirmed that doesn't
necessarily mean that the game is for
sure coming out that day now if you go
buy some of wb's other games Gotham
Knights for example it's art book and
the game are scheduled to release the
same day personally I think it would be
straight range if the art book released
before the game because there's the
potential for spoilers there right I
definitely think it makes a lot of sense
for it to actually release on the day
that the game comes out all that being
said I still want to caution folks on
the release date for the art book
because if you remember all the way back
in February when the Twitter account at
rolling Library actually broke the story
about inside editions to publish the art
and making of Hogwarts Legacy the
original date scheduled there was
September of 2022. it was actually
September 6th 2022 which again set off a
big Firestorm among fans hoping that hey
that's going to be the release date
right September of course this was back
in February before the state of play so
he didn't even know half of what we know
about the game now but we eventually saw
that updated to now reflect December 6th
now another piece of information here
that I haven't really seen a lot of
folks talk about if you go back to that
article from Rolling Library he posted
an update on February 9th which talked
about the fact that the date was being
changed however the date that he shows
on Amazon UK was December 6 all the way
back then so maybe it changed to
December 31st after this and then they
changed it back again to December 6th I
don't know but I do think it's important
that we all remember something that
rolling Library included in that article
here I'll just go ahead and quote this
is normal in the publication world where
release dates are not set in stone and
can change especially if we are months
away from it it is not possible to know
right now which one will be the final
release date of the book until it is
confirmed by the publisher close quote
so just to be clear here these dates
have not been confirmed by the publisher
and even if they were that wouldn't
necessarily mean that Hogwarts Legacy is
releasing December 6th now I'll be
honest with you guys I've continued to
hear some Rumblings that the game is
potentially going to be delayed to next
year so fans may need to brace
themselves for that possibility now for
the good news though everything seems to
be adding up all these little kind of
leaks that are starting to trickle out
everything seems to be leading up to the
fact that we are going to get something
soon now I made a post back in early
July saying that I thought a big
announcement was coming soon we've been
almost a month out from that now clearly
we haven't had a big announcement so I
was definitely wrong there I thought it
was going to happen mid-july Late July
now here we are early August so I am
still expecting something soon I mean I
think August early September at the
absolute latest guys I mean I think
Avalanche would almost have to give some
sort of release date update by early
September I mean either way if the game
is going to get pushed then you really
need to let people know at that point
that it's going to get pushed to next
year and if it's not well then hey I
mean September October November December
it's here that is not a lot of marketing
build up time for the masses for the
Casual fans now I know all of us we've
been following every little piece of
information that's trickled out about
this game but you gotta remember they
want to reach a much wider audience than
those of us who have been kind of
following things every week yes we are
the core audience still can be wrong
guys they definitely want us but they
know they have us they have our
attention but they want to reach even
more so they want to reach all these
casual Harry Potter fans they're gonna
do TV campaigns they're gonna run ads
probably on YouTube and other websites
Sony obviously has a huge role in the
marketing of Hogwarts Legacy so this is
going to get a pretty big marketing push
and I think that three four month range
is sort of the minimum that you would
want to see for that build up now that
doesn't mean you're gonna have something
every single week so we'll keep our
fingers crossed for August I still think
we're gonna get an ASMR pretty soon and
then hopefully a release date and
collector's edition announcement soon as
well and then I'm not even gonna get
into the other rumor that just hit today
about the potential for a Playstation
Showcase in August but if it happens
then that would certainly be another
great opportunity for an announcement on
Hogwarts Legacy now I have been wanting
a game like this for so long guys and if
you want to hear my story of why I am so
excited then check out the video on the
right side of your screen now and all
the other Hogwarts Legacy content on the
channel as always thank you all so much
for watching I'll talk to you again soon